I am inevitable I am tractors Seto let
me know if you need a quarterback next
year
hello Derrick yeah I think I'll go to
space for a little bit going forward now
that Brady has been defeated the AFC has
returned after a four-year absence I
don't care if he got defeated no I can
take away his sixth on team trip to
Miami bro think of all the bespoke suits
at Smith this is Mysterio polo
hey kid I think it's real cute when you
run around it without the threat of
Patriots his dimension the NFC has grown
new monsters every year you should be
America's favourite yo nerds the kid had
no idea I'm just following Kyle system
we have the lead just run it we see you
watching the episode just one dimension
State Farm can I finish it okay yeah
it's legendary
[Music]
it's dopest crap
hello I'm Jimmy Garoppolo Jimmy garage I
hate a very broad child back baby
activate defense sup I week to plan for
every happy but you lover
let me tell you why you're wrong a 30
tweets I got this whoa can you smell
what the new croc is cooking with our
schemes we can make you see any
I think I did the time thing again
Patrick I mean rim pew pew battle it
back here what's this BAM
kid was a bomb right yeah got it
whatever scribe this channel